[Musique]
le département annonce en conférence de
presse ses propositions pour soutenir
l'avenir de la filière canne à la
réunion la première vise à augmenter le
taux d' aide à l'heure aux plantations
de 50%
cette aide sera revalorisée à 90%
le département a voulu lancer un signe
fort en direction du monde agricole
notamment une proposition immédiate qui
est de porter à 90 % l'aide à la
replantation c'est une première
proposition la deuxième c'est qu'on se
pose maintenant clairement la question
de l'avenir quelle agriculture pour la
réunion et pour cela nous proposons de
mettre en place dès le mois de septembre
des assises pour ouvrir cette réflexion
avec l'ensemble des acteurs du monde
agricole avec l'état avec la région
mais rassembler autour de nous
l'ensemble des personnes qui croient en
l'avenir du monde agricole à la réunion
les premières assises de ces réflexions
sont prévues dès le mois de septembre
prochain
encore mobilisés dans la renégociation
de la convention canne
les planteurs sont satisfaits de ces
aides apportées par le département
une excellente nouvelle je dirais parce
qu'elle n'avait pas évolué depuis
plusieurs années et aujourd'hui cette
nouvelle ne fait que le peu que nous
enchanter dans la mesure où et tout ce
qui tourne autour de la plantation
notamment les intrants engrais et
herbicides avec ont augmenté de façon
extraordinaire s'est dégradée donc cette
augmentation cette augmentation de
l'ader à la plantation effectivement une
véritable acteur du développement
agricole à la réunion le département
soutient la filière canne sucre
ces aides apporteront de meilleurs
revenus aux planteurs et des canes plus
riches en sucre aux usiniers améliorant
ainsi leur seuil de rentabilité
[Musique]